this
is number eight of my caption contest
videos in which
i put out a picture in my community tab
in
youtube and people say what they want to
about it and i pick the best
of the comments and answers for them
so this time around i had a picture and
it's from a flight that i took
i'm not sure when or where this
was except for going by
how little white there is in my beard it
was from
quite a while ago and already back then
people had started saying oh this guy
kind of looks like and sounds like the
dude from the big lebowski
and so when we got a can
that this is back when coke was doing
all these names on the can
there was one that i got that said
share a coke with dude so i thought that
could be quite interesting to have
people
comment on and as you can guess there
were a lot of dude references here's the
best one
i thought the dude aboards okay so
that's clever right
the dude is on the plane and then there
were a whole bunch of other
dude references so i've gathered them
here
in one place you can see that right the
dude abides of course
i see dude and i click dudeism on board
the sum of all philosophy equals dude
you do give off a lebowski feel and then
finally there's a great
name mad dog martha saying when he
abides
and then there was another good one here
gregory
abides okay so yeah i get called the
dude quite a bit
and then there was another good lebowski
thing careful man there's a beverage
here right
so that is from the movie and i thought
that was you know
kind of a clever line for it there were
some others that were drawn from the
movie but i'm going to jump right into
the other
captions and from this point on they're
all having to do with philosophy in one
way or another
so here's a great one when someone in
first class throws a
fit over high expectations and they
upgrade
one of the stoics from coach that would
be
me although i'm not actually a stoic i
just incorporate a lot of stoicism
i don't know if i was in first class or
not but
you know that's kind of a good picture
then there were
here's another one from ancient
philosophy what do you say about my
pouring out a libation
out of this cup to someone is it allowed
or not that is a reference to
plato's fedo and the famous death scene
in that dialogue where socrates is going
to be drinking hemlock which has been
administrated by the guard and the guard
actually says no no
you know we measured it out you can't
you have to drink the whole thing
at this point they switched to hegel
stuff so here's a good one
beginners read hegel's books to
understand his philosophy
i drink his philosophy to
understand him so yeah a lot to unpack
there
i'm not going to try to delve too deep
into it in this
jokey one but you know drinking
philosophy
if we could do that that would be kind
of cool i think
you can see in that also a reference to
plato's symposium
where there's this idea that we could
like transfer philosophy from
one person to another like going through
a
thread or bit of yarn like capillary
action right
here's another one phenomenology of
spirit mixers much shorter much more
terse but this is quite good you know um
playing off of the double sense of
spirit in this case
so i very much liked that one here's
another good one
when you don't have to read hegel
anymore
now i'm not at that point where i don't
have to read hegel i have been reading
him for
quite a long time but i still have to go
back to the text
in part because my memory is not great
uh
then we have and here's almost like a
commercial or
sponsorship thing and today's half hour
hegel is sponsored by the refreshing
taste of coca-cola get a can today so
you can refresh your mind after
reading some hegel that's often
something that we do need to do
hegel is a tough read and then we
leave hegel and behind here's a good
reference
to one of the key psychological
uh innovators pictured here is the
demonstration of the pleasure principle
as in freudian psychoanalysis
well yes and no i mean i do enjoy a coke
and uh all sorts of other things are
nice about that i'm sure the seats were
decent in the flight but
if i'm indulging myself on the pleasure
principle which is like let's get as
much pleasure as possible out of life
it ain't gonna be just drinking a coke
so
and finally here's the last one bio
power in soda form that's a reference to
michel foucault and people who have come
after him invoking this notion of bio
power
right power over life and so how does
that fit in with the dude i'm not quite
sure but it was kind of a cool thing
to say so we'll do more of these caption
contests keep your eyes peeled for them
you can jump
in on them you want to have something
funny to say
something apt something that'll get your
caption into the video thanks to
everybody who contributed
and that's all for this one
you